je vois tes yeux je suis amoureux quand
je vois ton cul je suis très déçu
[Applaudissements]
quel accueille ça va très bien alors
vous avez déclaré récemment à la
télévision je suis obligé d'être festif
et souriant
dans la vie j'ai plus de tendance à être
marginal et associable mais si vous
voulez faire la gueule il y a pas de
problème
vous pouvez faire la guerre on s'en fout
non au contraire comme je suis à la télé
je crois qu'il faut être festif et
souriant mais ce que je voulais dire en
fait c'était que j'étais ambivalent
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas parce que je
suis festif et souriant que j'ai pas une
vie intérieure où j'ai découvertes voilà
vous avez peur quand vous prenne pour un
beau mec et point barre quoi ouais non
c'est pas ça c'est que je pense que je
suis quelqu'un d'assez
tiraillé entre plusieurs choses alors
c'est vrai que comme à la télévision on
a toujours choisi comme il faut être gay
il faut trouver des trucs qui swing et
tout ça on a toujours choisi mes
chansons les plus légères en laissant
dans l'ombre peut-être dans mes albums
des chansons un peu plus graves et soit
mais c'est pas grave parce que je joue
le jeu c'est le jeu de la télévision
quand on passe à 20h30 on va pas faire
chier le monde avec des trucs
c'est ça quoi mais alors que lui il s'en
branle il fait la gueule il s'en fout
lui il est il passe
en tous les cas vous avez pas de quoi
faire la gueule parce que votre dernier
album jazz est la Nouvelle-Orléans est
déjà 5e du top album c'est pas mal c'est
la première fois que ça m'arrive bah oui
ça monte très vite là ouais c'est c'est
en concurrence
je suis content qui est derrière il est
quand même derrière
d'accord oui c'est vrai
moi je chante pas
ira plus
alors le premier jour je vois tes yeux
je suis amoureux quand je vois ton cul
je suis très déçu
j'ai écrit ça tout à l'heure en
puissance
alors ce qui est très marrant ce qui est
très marrant à gagner brillant c'est que
le premier album c'était à
Saint-Germain-des-Prés après il y a Cuba
après une Dany Brillant en Italie
maintenant c'est Dany Brillant la
Nouvelle-Orléans est-ce que vous allez
faire Dany Brillant fait l'espace
Dany Brillant à Saint-Tropez
pourquoi pas mais je vais toujours dans
les marchés sur Dany Brillant
Denis
en fait je vais toujours dans des ordres
je vais toujours dans les berceaux où
son nez musique que j'aime et cette fois
il y avait les musiciens de Harry
Connick Junior ce qui ne gâche rien
quand même quand on écoute le disque
quoi c'est Harry Connick Junior qui
prête jamais son groupe
me l'a prêté et j'ai enregistré là-bas
avec un big band c'est la première fois
de ma vie que ça arrive et je suis
content que un album de jazz parce que
c'est vraiment un album de jazz pur à
100%
étaient arrivés comme ça en tête du Top
parce que d'habitude c'est une musique
pour une minorité c'est pas une musique
justement de
jazz et aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
que les gens envie d'écouter d'autres
choses
pour garder l'énergie oh là là là là là
là là là
il est incorrigible
votre mari est en coulisse je vous
rappelle quand même alors c'est un
disque qui dédié à votre Père qui est
mort il y a deux ans vous dites on est
passé à côté l'un de l'autre
peut-être parce que lui n'avait pas
connu le sien mais vous avez du mal à
communiquer tous les deux ouais bah
comme beaucoup de gens Gérard en parler
nous on a un problème de génération
j'avais un père qui est c'est pas les
pères copains d'aujourd'hui l'autorité
il y avait un respect et donc quand je
dis par exemple je voulais être chanteur
ou acteur il a dit quand tu seras
chanteur je suis président de la
République donc vraiment il croyait pas
tellement et puis donc un jour elle m'a
vu à la télé quelques années après il
s'est mis à pleurer et en fait on n'a
jamais vraiment communiqué et on est
passé dans la politique après ça lui a
pas donné envie et voilà et vous l'avez
fait une chanson qui s'appelle à mon
père et il est un petit peu immortalisé
d'une certaine façon maintenant avec une
chanson en fait je sais pas combien de
temps dure une chanson mais c'est vrai
que
ça prolonge un peu sa vie et j'ai
raconté toute sa vie en 6 minutes
c'était un émigré qui en a bavé qui a eu
des épreuves et tout ça
il a jamais dépassé le SMIC
et ben on met en revanche il nous a
léguer excusez moi je suis un peu ému
quand j'en parle mais il nous a légué
une
un optimisme
malgré les difficultés tout ça de rester
d'y croire encore alors il y a une autre
chanson qui s'appelle un jour c'est sur
la difficulté du couple alors vous vous
avez été au début complètement embarqué
dans l'amour fusionnel voilà et puis
maintenant vous avez compris quoi
c'est-à-dire que j'ai compris parce que
j'étais quelqu'un d'accessivement jaloux
et quand je dis comme je dis dans ma
chanson si l'amour nous enchaîne un jour
il finira j'ai compris qu'en fait dans
un couple on est trois il y a l'homme la
femme et le couple et en fait il faut
garder une distance il faut avoir chacun
sa vie c'est basé sur la confiance
évidemment mais on doit avoir sa vie
d'homme sa vie de femme pour la femme
bien sûr et puis avoir sa vie de couple
et la vie de couple en fait se nourrit
de chacun des non mais c'est juste que
vous dites vous vous en êtes aux
chambres séparées pour le moment voilà
et ça ça crée une distance
séparés bon bah à plus tard ça vous avez
moi je suis assez d'accord avec ça
de séparées et aussi sur un truc que
vous dites c'est qu'il faut se marier à
40 ans oui ça c'est vrai
je me suis marié à 21 ans dans c'était
c'était un peu trop tôt j'étais pas
formé mais je crois qu'à 40 ans c'est
bien parce qu'on est un peu jeune enfin
forgé je sais pas comment dire mais
j'avais pas l'expérience oui non mais
j'avais déjà tout ce qu'il faut mais
et je savais comment m'en servir mais si
vous voulez je suis partisan de la vie à
deux je suis pas du tout pour le célibat
je pense que dans la vie il faut faire
un chemin côte à côte et pour s'épauler
ça c'est très important mais à 40 ans un
homme a fait pratiquement toutes les
expériences il est revenu de tout et je
pense qu'il est mûr pour partager et
changer avec quelqu'un
vie privée tout ça on sait pas on sait
pas grand chose puisque j'ai pas encore
40 ans je n’ai pas encore marié non mais
c'est vrai on sait pas très bien avec
qui vous vous fricotez non on sait pas
vous aimez pas vous faire remarquer
comme mec
je trouve que c'est pas intéressant ce
que je fais enfin j'ai l'impression que
les gens me connaissent pour m'amuser
pour mes trucs ma vie privée je sais pas
si c'est bah écoutez pour vous permettre
d'être discret on va faire une interview
de dos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Dany Brillant
c'est plus facile de répondre à
l'interview quand on tourne le dos aux
gens
ah non pas du tout je trouve que
justement dans il y a une grande règle
dans le musical c'est qu'il faut jamais
tourner le dos quand on est de dos on a
envie de leur dire quoi téléspectateurs
vivement que je revienne devant parce
que j'ai besoin de vous regarder parce
que là je comprends pas ce qui se passe
là enfin je regarde le public remarqué
je regarde le public mais pas le
spectateur
c'est plus dur de tourner le dos au
téléspectateurs ou d'être face au public
c'est plus dur de tourner le dos en tout
cas pour le métier que j'ai choisi je
crois que c'est c'est basé sur l'échange
alors quand on tourne au dos je trouve
c'est une forme de mépris quand même
comment on fait pour exprimer une
émotion quand on est de dos vous savez
que d'après l'acteur studio si vous êtes
dans un état émotionnel et ben on sent
même votre émotion d'eau ça c'est les
très grands acteurs c'est la guerre de
Niro faites voir une émotion là par
exemple l'abattement vous êtes de dos
c'est bien joué oh
alors
maintenant vous êtes dodo qu'est-ce que
vous pourriez me dire que vous n'osez
pas me dire quand vous êtes de face
je voulais vous dire que je vous ai
toujours adoré ah oui ça c'est bien de
me le dire dodo parce que d'un seul coup
moins gêné bah voilà
vous croyez que vous pouvez être
intéressant de
bah qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
bah vous êtes bien moi je trouve ah bah
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on gagne à pas vous
voir de face
c'est à dire si je si je reste trop de
dos comme ça et un moment je sais pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il va y avoir une
bagarre vous êtes curer le nez là par
exemple c'est parce que vous êtes de
vous êtes touché le curé non j'ai
caressé parce que j'avais de la poudre
enfin de maquillage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu